ich freue mich wirklich sehr auf das
gespräch weil wir unterschiedliche
sichtweisen auf das thema haben bin mir
sicher der blutdruck wird von anfang an
relativ hoch sein
ob jemand zur seite jetzt über jetzt
unterhalten sich zwei erwachsene frauen
heute geht es um islam und feminismus
geht das zusammen fragen wir uns und
wenn ja wie ja und dann haben wir zwei
kontrahentinnen die sich nichts schenken
werden netz lacalle die berühmte
islamkritikerin packt sowieso immer
kontroverse zählt esel auf den tisch
welche rolle hat die frau im islam und
darf sich sehr viele
menschenrechtsverletzungen hin auf der
anderen seite land sahin jedenfalls eine
bekannte feministin die in ihrem alter
ego lady [ __ ] ray dafür berühmt ist zu
provozieren durch kennen denen stand und
von der schlaghand ich hoffe dass sie
einsichten hat wenn nicht muss ich
leider die chin mir aktivieren und das
wird hart somit hat aber viel dafür
sorgt für sie ist der islam mitunter ein
system der unterdrückung das klingt
danach dass islam und feminismus
zumindest moderner feminismus gar nicht
zusammenpassen wenn wir uns einen
islamischen staat uns genau anschauen es
gibt da kann kaum raum kaum möglichkeit
dass frauen sich vielleicht können sich
einzeln zu feminismus sich bekennen aber
dass sie eine hohe bewerben und
tatsächlich auch für die rechte der frau
und was tun können können die frauen
nicht und das schaue ich mir ja auch
genau an diese diese werte die eben
diesen islamischen ländern gelebt werden
die der frauen in der sozialisation
bereits gegeben wird erscheint es gibt
tatsächlich viele menschen die sagen mit
dem islam verbinden sie nicht nicht
grundsätzlich aber doch zu weiten teilen
patriarchale strukturen mit einem
modernen feminismus geht das nicht
zusammen was antworten sie also ich
würde erstmal grundsätzlich sagen dass
wir nicht über den islam sprechen
sollten weil es gibt islamische
community ist die sind unterschiedlich
die sind unterschiedlicher ethnischer
natur ob wir von einem arabischen islam
sprechen türkischen islam und dann gibt
es auch noch unterschiedliche politische
bewegungen und die darf man nicht
irgendwie übersehen das problem der
bisherigen debatte debatten um islam und
feminismus und da hat frau kelek auch
immer gut mitgemischt
das ist zu einseitig ist und zu
undifferenziert und pauschalisiert was
ich damit meine
wenn wir das kopftuch als beispiel
nehmen
kopf durch diskussion aber dass wandelte
sich dann so ein bisschen so sei es ist
ein symbol diskussion und dann kam der
relativ schnell zu des pudels kern
ich möchte das konkretisiert wird und
genau genannt wird welches kopftuch
genau gemeint ist man muss
differenzieren das kopftuch ist im
ursprünglichen sinne patriarchalisch ja
aber im individuellen also wenn die
kopftuchträgerin das sozusagen positiv
reclaim und ab ändert kann es sogar
emanzipatorisches und feministische
zeichen sein also es gibt so viele
fragen
und dann soll ich über par für minister
kopftuchträgerinnen sprechen um die
freunde der islam kann nur mit dieser
form von wissen dieser rolle von frau
sie gehört ihnen die familie und sie
gehört einem mann der sie genommen hat
dass es die form das ist diese ideale
form die in islamischen ländern gelebt
wird und ein teil davon dass sie wenn
sie das haus verlässt das kopftuch
tragen sollte
[Musik]
ich stimme nicht zu dass sie das
pauschal für alle kopftuchträgerinnen
anwendet und von dem kopftuch spricht
und von dem islam und ich habe sie eben
noch mal gehört sie sagen in islamischen
ländern also worauf bezieht sich jetzt
auf alle islamischen länder da gibt es
ja auch noch mal unterschiede jetzt ist
dass davids fraser und ich differenziere
und ich lege wert drauf und ich streite
mich auch mit menschen und was sich auch
an in kritisieren muss frau kelek ist
die tatsache dass sie mit diesem
einseitigen diskurs leider auch
rechtspopulisten in die hände spielen
und diese negative fahren das finde ich
schade wir leben in einer gesellschaft
die post rechtsruck lebt ja wo wieder
rassistische anschläge normal geworden
sind und gerade in dieser gesellschaft
müssen wir differenziert handeln damit
wir irgendwie nicht die falschen
gewinnen lassen also sehr alte es ist ja
eine alte diskussion wie muss man
realistisch debatten führen wie welche
rolle spielt dabei rassismus wem spielt
man in die hände
[Musik]
und wenn wir die pauschalisierung reden
ich zitiere mal kurz aus ihrem buch die
familie ist das haus des islam frauen
sind in diesem haus gefangenen die frau
ist in der arabischen kultur das
verraten der geschlecht können sie
nachvollziehen dass ihnen
pauschalisierung manchmal vorgeworfen
wird bei solchen sätzen
ja also allein zu sagen was meinen sie
mit einer islamischen staat und sie
haben gerade promoviert da wundere ich
mich jetzt wirklich wie sie auf die welt
schauen ja es ist schreckt mich sogar
ich bin auch schockiert darüber dass so
jemand die so feministisch ist die
zusammenhänge nicht sieht diese
islamischen ländern denn wir uns sie
werden wir sie genau anschauen
da stellen sie fest dass es über 45
ländern ein islamisches familienrecht
gebrechen oder welches land man also
sind komplett 45 länder gesichert über
einen haufen geschmissen
das hochgradig problematisch das ist
veraltet wir sind weiter wir müssen
weitermachen
dies ist recht sagt ganz klar was die
frau davon was dich sie ist sie hat
überhaupt kein daseinsberechtigung nach
diesem rechtssystem
sie braucht einen vormund dass sie
überhaupt das haus verlassen darf dass
sie ein irgendwas unterschreiben darf
also sie ist ein recht loses wesen und
das sind über eine milliarde von
menschen die unter diesem konzept leben
und auch leiden würden wir müssen glaube
ich so ein bisschen sortieren wir haben
gerade über den vorwurf der
pauschalisierung ich sage jetzt mal im
deutschen diskurs raum ihr eigentlich
jetzt mal gesprochen also und der
vorwurf stand im raum dass sie zu
pauschalisierend hierzulande
argumentieren würden und darauf wollten
wir eigentlich antwort ich habe das
möchte ich auch den frauen sich hier
bewusst für ein kopftuch sich
entscheiden bewusst wie eine islamische
welt entscheiden dann setzt sich das im
verhältnis zu den ländern wo diese
menschen herkommen und da schaue ich mir
schon diese herkunftsländer an und sagen
moment da gibt's dieses islamische
familienrecht das möchte sie hier auch
haben obwohl sie hier in der demokratie
lebt ich wir können das nicht
voneinander trennen
deshalb ist das überhaupt keine
pauschalisierung sind
von den passagier ums vorwürfen die
gegen sie erhoben wurde da musste ich ja
zwei drei mal nachfragen und sie hat
eigentlich bis zum schluss nie deutlich
position bezogen
ich würde gerne versuchen irgendwie so
ein bisschen bei den themen zu bleiben
also der vorwurf der im raum stand war
die pauschalisierung hilft den falschen
leuten da kommen wir noch mal zurück da
können sie auch gleich noch mal darauf
antworten aber tatsächlich sie werden ja
instrumentalisieren zum beispiel afd la
die tweets erzeugen mit mit zitaten aus
ihrem buch das war auch schon immer so
das ist ja der vorwurf der gerade kam
wie gehen sie damit um dass fixe ja auch
sie wollen das ja nicht mich
interessiert das nicht ich habe mit
diesen leuten nichts zu tun das ist mir
eigentlich egal wer mich zitiert so und
das finde ich ein bisschen ignorant ich
kümmere mich um eine rechts bewegung
innerhalb der muslimischen gesellschaft
die ist viel viel stärker viel extremer
haben sie denn keine angst dass sie
instrumentalisiert werden von islamisten
klar und die ganze rechte bewegung was
in der islamischen woche
das ist nicht japan werde wie denn wie
man in der das sie denn verschiedene
unterschiedliche art und weise ich guck
mir haben wo ich artikel veröffentlichen
ich guck mir an mit was für menschen
nicht zusammenarbeiten also wenn sie
eine bestimmte gruppe in der gesetzten
dieser gesellschaft so repräsentiert
dann sage ich oh gott ich muss noch viel
viel viel mehr auftreten und
von über den politischen islam zum
beispiel sprechen weil das wenn sie auf
pauschal lässt dass sie zum beispiel
nicht aufregt dass die moschee vertreter
seit jahrzehnten die politik vertritt
von simone wendler von thilo sarrazin
zitiert ja ich wollte sie aber lasse das
nicht aus sondern sind noch was im kopf
genau ich habe alle wissen das ist sehr
schön sehr schön aber warum sie warum
haben sie noch nie noch nie was dagegen
geschrieben
der politik sind die verbände genau
polizei unterwandert seit jahrzehnten
dieses land mit ihrem politischen islam
warum tun sie da nichts
warum ist das nicht ihr thema das ist
gefährlich so jetzt möchte ich aber ganz
kurz damit wäre das verrat
es gab zwei oder drei situationen in
denen ich versucht habe die eine oder
auch die andere einzufangen und das ging
aber nicht weil sie dann doch beide
persönlich dann doch so angriffspunkt
muss ich doch sagen wir haben gegen sie
überhaupt gar keine ahnung was ich
bisher geschrieben haben und sie haben
auch an scheint mein buch nicht gelesen
ich über diese kritik sehr wohl am
islamischen verbänden görisch ich sage
muslimbrüderschaft ich sage dass das der
politisierte islamistische zweig ist
dass das hoch problematisch ist und dass
die frauen die da zu schweigen dass das
kein feminismus ist und nur für mich
auch problematisch das sage ich aber das
haben sie anscheinend nicht gelesen und
haben keine kenntnis
[Musik]
würde gerne versuchen mal irgendwie ein
bisschen konstruktiven die zukunft zu
blicken
denn das wäre ja dass das hilfreich was
schlagen sie endlich sie kommen wir
sonst nicht zu wollen was schlagen sie
denn was was schlagen sie denn nun
vorerst mal ist dieser kritische diskurs
wichtig also solche debatten wie hier
die sind wichtig dass man sich
miteinander streitet dass man
gegenseitig diese ansichten austausch
glaube das was diese sendung schafft
schaffen kann im besten fall nämlich
unterschiedliche standpunkte
herausarbeiten an denen man sich dann
als zuschauer bleiben kann
das ist heute gelungen und im
politischen sinne finde ich es wichtig
dass viel mehr sensibilisiert wird neben
rassismus auch für islamistische
strukturen und ich würde es für die
zukunft um ihre frage zu beantworten
wichtig finden dass wir diese
undifferenzierten pauschalisierten ist
meines erachtens um fundierten diskurse
aller keller endlich mal überwinden und
ein feministischen queer feministischen
rassismus kritischen empirisch belegten
diskurs führen wie auch beim klimawandel
sie sehen ja im politischen islam den
ursprung vielen übels sag ich jetzt mal
ich versuche jetzt mal so allgemein wie
möglich zu halten
was schlagen sie also vor islam
abschaffen nein was heißt ja abschaffen
müssen uns die strukturen anschauen und
ich habe das jetzt mit meinem letzten
buch wieder getan
wir müssen unter uns tatsächlich eine
debattenkultur entwickeln und ich bin
ihnen dankbar auch für dieses podium und
auch für viele andere podien wo wir
kontroverser tatsächlich diskutieren
können wir haben sozusagen sozusagen an
geprägt und angefangen so zusagt
angerissen darüber zu sprechen dass wir
uns als menschen und als denkende
menschen gegenseitig respektieren
das ist mir nicht mit ja am ende habe
ich doch fast schon versöhnliche töne
gehört wir werden diese diskussion
natürlich nicht zu ende und ems liga
version und konsens gründen wir müssen
wir das nennen weil person ist mir dann
zu lieb und und das hat dann mit
kollegen auch schon entschieden
das war natürlich nicht der anspruch die
diskussion hier wirklich zu einem ende
zu führen
ich glaube es ist dennoch wichtig dass
wir sie immer wieder und immer wieder
neu führen und ich sage ganz herzlichen
dank für ihre impulse netzwerk und real
scheint vielen dank dafür
[Applaus]